and welcome everyone to our Bleacher
Report NCAA digital March Madness men's
basketball bracket predictions here on
selections Sunday night uh we are doing
this about oh about 90 minutes
uh or more after the bracket was
revealed uh so these are all quick takes
but I know you will hold me to them
so let's start with the South bracket uh
Alabama will take is the number one seed
there that will take on the winner of
Texas
um Corpus Christi Southeast Missouri uh
out of the ovc uh obviously I have an
Alabama advancing
then the next round Maryland West
Virginia this could be a great game uh
real physical both teams are gonna
really try to just sort of bully each
other
um you know West Virginia's played much
better of late but I'm going to lean
Marilyn with Jamir young being the star
from this game so we're an Alabama
Maryland matchup and I'm going to go
down the list and then keep going across
the United States College of Charleston
uh this is a 5-12 matchup everyone was
of course would love to pick Pat
Kelsey's cougars uh but I love the
Aztecs I saw them earlier in the season
they won the Mountain West a very good
Mountain West Conference so I think this
is where Charleston's run of Cinderella
ends despite winning more than 30 Games
Virginia Furman the paladins uh first
time in a long time they're in the NCAA
tournament uh the Cavaliers lost to Duke
made it a nice late run in the ACC
tournament title game but I don't think
Furman has enough to beat Virginia I go
to Virginia so we have a Virginia San
Diego State matchup uh continuing down
Creighton NC State
I don't think NC State should be in I
thought Rutgers should be in over NC
State NC State one quad one win I didn't
think they deserved it Creighton I think
one of the better offenses in the
country I think creating Advance is over
so I had Creighton over NC State Baylor
Santa Barbara another one that I know
people like the Gauchos they won the big
West uh but I I I know Baylor lost to
Iowa state but I have more faith than
Baylor Bears
um so I would go with Baylor over Santa
Barbara Missouri Utah State
um again Utah State a team that I think
should get in over Rutgers uh and uh I
don't think they're gonna last long
either I love what Kobe Brown Dennis
Gates uh have done with the Tigers
Missouri advances
um Arizona Princeton Princeton upset
Yale even though it was at Princeton to
win the ivy on Sunday but Arizona just
won the Pac-12 tournament title I have
Arizona advancing past Princeton all
right so now you got Alabama Maryland
good match with young and quarterly but
um I think there's too much especially
with Brandon Miller I think it's a tough
matchup for Maryland I got Alabama
advancing I like the city of Virginia
this could be a this game by the way
that game seriously Virginia is going to
be neither team may get to 60. that is
going to be an absolute defensive
struggle both very good defensive
coaches and teams I like San Diego State
to upset Virginia uh and advance to the
sweet 16. uh continuing down this is
where Creighton's offense is too much
for Baylor remember Creighton was picked
to win the Big East in the beginning of
the season I think Creighton advances
Missouri Arizona uh I love Arizona they
went through a rough patch but I love
the way they played in the Pac-12
tournament
um they've got the biggest match Ryan
kalkbrenner so I've got Arizona
advancing against Creighton so now you
have Alabama senior State Creighton
Arizona is in the South
um in Louisville Alabama will beat San
Diego State
taking on a rematch of the Maui
Invitational game uh which is Arizona
versus Creighton okay uh and
um Arizona beat Creighton in that game
I got them doing again so now we have an
Alabama Arizona Elite eight matchup in
Louisville
this is where I think Alabama's run ends
the Biggs of Arizona
are going to be too much for Alabama
Kirk Risa it's kind of a great game I
got I was high in Arizona early in the
year
and I got them coming out of here to go
to the Final Four
so two seed out of the South
let's go down uh down to the east
so we're on the left side uh of the
bracket
um in the East Purdue is the number one
seed
uh and Purdue is going to take on the
winner of
Texas Southern
Fairleigh Dickinson Purdue will win
easily then you've got Memphis taking on
Florida Atlantic Memphis just beat
Houston in the American Athletic
Conference title game on say uh for
y'all have had a great season but I
think Memphis is playing well at the
right time I got Memphis advancing to
play Purdue
Duke Orel Roberts uh Jeremy roach versus
Max acemus uh remember they went to the
Sweet 16 a couple years ago but Duke's
playing its best basketball of the
season I have Duke advancing past Oru uh
Tennessee taking on the Cajuns there
even though Tennessee is not played as
well they don't have another point guard
anymore I like the volunteers advancing
to take on Duke
Kentucky Providence I know everyone's
making a big deal about Bryce Hopkins
but he has not played as well lately so
I know Kentucky lost the Vanderbilt
Providence is on a real big skid I like
the Wildcats advancing K-State Montana
State K-State got Islands the Big 12
tournament but I love Marquis Noel and
um uh kianti Johnson that one two punch
I got K-State advancing
Montana's excuse Michigan State taking
on USC these two very
similar very similar teams okay very
similar teams
and uh they've both been very
inconsistent I love the Tyson Walker
boogie boogie Ellis matchup
but we don't know which team we're gonna
get but I think in this matchup we will
get the good Michigan state so they will
advance Marquette Vermont this is not
Tommy Brennan's Vermont even though John
Becker's done a great job I don't see
your first round upset for Vermont
Marquette just won the Big East regular
season and Conference tournament title
so I got Marquette advancing
now Purdue Memphis believe it or not I
think
this game could be the toughest game for
Purdue in this bracket
you got length they got size they got
athleticism Memphis has the goods to
beat Purdue
but I don't know if they have the
discipline even though their press could
really bother those young guards
I think they'll follow out against that
key I got Purdue
Duke Tennessee Tennessee's just too
banged up Duke advances
K-State against Kentucky I actually when
uh Bruce Weber was the coach of K-State
I was there when they beat Kentucky
years ago I think they do it again
K-State advances Marquette I trust him
more than Michigan State I got Marquette
taking on Kansas State
um
you know two-way Wiggins is saying I'm
picking the higher seat every time
um you know uh
there are a couple upsets here
but um
you do what you want to do that's fine
um
Purdue versus Duke I saw this game it
was in Portland
Kyle filpowski could not handle zakiri I
was there uh I feel like the same thing
is going to happen again Zach Edie has
taken his game believe it or not to
another level in Chicago
um so Purdue Advance is past due
and these games will be Madison Square
Garden which by the way Duke will have a
great crowd at the Garden
K-State Marquette
Marquette just played at the Garden had
a tremendous crowd uh and I think they
will advance in the garden within a
couple weeks BK state
by the way that colic Noel matchup would
be great Mark K-State so now we got a
one two again back to back regions
uh Purdue versus Marquette this game
happened early in the season in the Gava
games obviously Marquette is much better
they gave Purdue a good game
but I think they beat him again for new
beats Marquette again so I have Purdue
advancing to take on Arizona
in Houston
now let's go up to the upper right
uh
uh portion
um this is the
Midwest bracket
games will be in Kansas City so someone
wanted some upsets I got some upsets
here for you man
Houston over Northern Kentucky not an
upset
Iowa outscores Auburn Aubry can't score
Indiana beating Kent State I'm gonna go
with the good Indiana
that we saw oh I skipped one I'm sorry
uh Miami will be drink even though
Miami's banged up so we have Iowa Miami
and then we have Indiana over Kent State
so that second round Houston Iowa Miami
Indiana
now
Iowa state versus the winner Mississippi
State Pitt
again Grinders these will be grinder
games Iowa State just knocked off Baylor
I like the way Iowa State defends I got
Iowa State advance
remember they were in the the sweet 16
last year
a m Penn State
okay man yeah I haven't picked a single
upset a little crying there guy here you
go
Penn State beats Texas A M
Penn State will beat Texas A M
um Xavier of course goes over Kennesaw
State so Penn State beats Texas A M
m
they will not be able to handle Jalen
Pickett Seth Lonnie and Andrew Funk are
going to make shots Adam has not seen a
team like Penn State
Texas Colgate
Colgate could be Texas because they can
make threes but Texas just won the big
12. they will advance so now we have one
potential sleeper correct okay
now you want upsets my friend
Iowa over Houston okay Iowa over Houston
they can score Houston cannot score as
well
that game is going to be in the 70s or
80s
Miami Indiana
that we're getting the good Indiana here
Indiana advances
Iowa State Xavier
Iowa State
beat Xavier in a grinder physical game
Penn State Texas again
Penn State had the run to the Big Ten
Tournament title game they knock off
Texas
so if there was a big ten heavy bracket
you're noticing there was one that I
have picked here
Iowa State Penn State
again
I love the offense of execution of Penn
State advancing in the bottom part and
up top
Indiana best Iowa
so we have an Indiana Iowa excuse me
Penn State matchup
in the elite eight
in Kansas City
Mike Woodson Trace Jackson Davis
jalenuchi Vino you know why they got
multiple Pros they got a pro coach
Indiana advances
now let's go to the last quadrant
a lot of haters by the way that are
chiming in here we'll get to some
questions in a moment let's finish the
bracket
all right West
and by the way this is my picks you
don't have to go buy my picks these are
my picks
Kansas taking on Howard good news Bill
self will be back I'm going with The
Jayhawks Illinois Arkansas two
inconsistent teams I don't trust
Arkansas at all I'm going to Illinois
you want more upsets I got one for you
St Mary's VCU if you watch the way VCU
played in the A-10 if you won the
regular season they won the conference
tournament I go VCU
uh
uh so we've got Illinois VCU then patino
UConn Yukon Iona this game is in Albany
so it's gonna be a great atmosphere with
the Yukon fans and the uh
and The gales fans and I'm going with
Yukon
so we have Kansas Illinois VCU Yukon
bottom right
TCU advances against the winner of ASU
Nevada which by the way I think will be
Arizona State
uh Gonzaga Grand Canyon
zags they're playing their best
basketball at the right time
Northwestern Boise Northwestern
Boise
I don't think you can run with boo Booey
good defensive team but they're going to
push the the tempo UCLA Asheville UCLA
advances even though they were down two
starters uh they played really well in
the late possession lost Arizona late
Saturday night so UCLA
then Kansas continues their run
they beat
Illinois
Yukon VCU that thing is going to be a
track meet but UConn's is better
TCU Gonzaga
again
TC is going to struggle with Timmy I
think Gonzaga advances
Northwestern UCLA I don't think
Northwestern has an answer for Jaime
Hawkes
UCL advances we get a rematch in Vegas
Gonzaga UCLA
uh this game rematch in the sweet 16
years ago I think that game was in
Oakland when Gonzaga with Adam Morrison
Gonzaga blew a huge lead usually came
back and won
so I've got
UCLA
uh advancing baskets I know they don't
have James Clark
so I've got
Kansas UCLA Kansas beats UConn in Vegas
then UCLA advances past Kansas
so
I've got a two a one a four and a two
so I've got only
one number one seeds you know number one
seed excuse me Purdue
so now this is our final four Arizona
Purdue with uh azulus and Omar Balo
going against zakidi trade cop and ren
that'd be a great big matchup
creasa going with those guards I think
this would be a great game
I have Purdue advancing
UCLA Indiana how about a couple of brand
names right there in the National
semi-final wow
um
but I like UCLA here everyone oh they
don't have the defensive player in the
impact 12 but every time we say things
like that
you know the team that has lost the
starter
a lot of times advances
so a Purdue UCLA final
um would be a great game
but
this is where
I'm just I'm gonna ride I think there's
no one he's a unicorn there's no one
like Zach Edie in the country and he has
taken his game with multiple 30-point
games to another level
and I think Purdue wins the national
championship
over UCLA
which would be in Houston which would be
a tremendous I think this would be a
great Final Four
would love this final four in Houston